[Musique]
quel est le rendement moyen du blé
cultivé au canada 3,5 tonnes à l'hectare
depuis 1960 les rendements de blé ont
plus que doublé au pays un bond
impressionnant
la sélection des variétés la
fertilisation et le contrôle des
mauvaises herbes sont trois facteurs qui
expliquent cette hausse
et pourtant même si on parle souvent des
prairies de l'ouest comme du grenier du
monde le canada tout comme les autres
grands pays producteurs est loin d'être
un champion des rendements à ce chapitre
la nouvelle-zélande est dans le peloton
de tête là bas les champs de blé souvent
irriguées à thème des rendements de 12
tonnes à l'hectare en moyenne en 2020 un
fermier de la nouvelle zélande a même
établi un record en produisant 17 tonnes
de blé à l'hectare l'ecosse et le nord
ouest de la france sont deux autres
régions au climat tempéré qui produisent
des rendements enviable avec 70 à
l'hectare les chants français sont en
moyenne deux fois plus productif que
ceux du canada et même si la france ne
peut pas compter sur de grandes
superficies ce pays est tout de même le
quatrième exportateur de blé au monde
la saison de croissance plus longue et
le climat plus doux en europe représente
de nets avantages par rapport au canada
et bonne nouvelle grâce à la recherche
les rendements continuent de s'améliorer
le problème c'est que 35 % de la
population mondiale dépend de cette
céréale pour sa survie et que la hausse
des rendements n'est pas assez rapide
pour satisfaire la demande d'un nombre
toujours croissant d'êtres humains sur
terre